oh I'm Arnold from from Harold it's a
cartoon from the 90s it's pretty popular
Nickelodeon
you want to do the countdown with me no
hey Walter let's do this football head
Thanksgiving is almost here and you know
what that means it's time to give thanks
to Craig Bartlett and Nickelodeon for
finally giving us they are the jungle
movie that's right we're finally gonna
get answers answers to questions that
we've had for 15 years
what happened aren't his parents will
Helda confess her love to Arnold what
the is wrong with Curley
well maybe not all the answers but Hey
Arnold fans across the world
old and new will at last get what
they've been so patient in receiving a
conclusion to the story to celebrate the
jungle movie we've picked out five
episodes from the show's run that are
the cream of the crop so for your
viewing pleasure these are the top five
best episodes of hey Arnold's number
five the vacant lot from season one
there are a few great episodes
surrounding Arnold and baseball but I
think this is the best one Arland the
neighborhood kids are getting tired of
the interruptions that go along with
playing baseball in the street soon they
find an unused lot full of garbage and
debris that they quickly clean up and
dubbed Gerald field after the kids leave
the adults in the neighborhood notice
there's a lot of space available there
and start to use the lot for their own
purposes when the kids return the next
day they see what their elders have done
and are unsure how to handle it I'm sure
a ton of kids who grew up playing
baseball can relate to this episode it's
authentic in the tone and attitude the
kids had an earl and Gerald friendship
goals this morning was full of trash and
now it's a baseball field
our baseball when the adults take over
the lot it gives the kids an antagonist
to defeat but not in pranking them are
bothering them until they leave the kids
have a better solution this is how the
lot look before we cleaned it up before
we turn it into Gerald field and before
you guys kicked us out so if you want
you know so badly you can have it just
the way we found it
Oh dump it's a classic episode and one
that has a great message there's only
one thing left to say number four Helga
on the couch from season four this
episode gave us a lot of background on
Helga's obsession with Arnold and her
complicated family life a psychologist
named dr. bliss is observing some of the
students at PS 118 and immediately
notices Helga's cruel demeanor it's
recommended that Helga have a one-on-one
session with the doctor and in that
session Helga's issues both at home and
at school are addressed and deeply delve
into her memories start as far back as
preschool as she slowly begins spilling
her guts to dr. bliss Helga was always a
fan favorite but in this episode we
really got to dig into what made her
tick some of hey Arnold's best episodes
feature the show's signature comedy I
was just getting ready for bed oh okay
well sleep well
yeesh what a nutjob they blended with
sincerely sad moments
[Music]
yeah in a minute okay go play outside
with you at this point in the show we've
heard how to confess her love for Arnold
su a few choice people but not on this
scale and brain umber 3 Arnold's
Christmas from season 1 Arnold trying to
find mr. Wynn's daughter is one of this
fan bases fondest memories on the
rewatch it holds all of that emotion
intact
the boarding house is drawing for Secret
Santa and Arnold gets mr. wint
struggling to find out what he wants for
Christmas
Arnold learns of Wynn's long-lost
daughter my they were separated decades
ago and the reunion would be the perfect
gift for the lonely border arnold sets
out to find my but it's not easy as he
runs into several roadblocks
Helga hears of Arnold's problem and
secretly does her best to help this show
could always draw you in with its pure
sentiment and sympathetic characters
Arnold's Christmas is arguably the
greatest example of that mr. Wynn's
flashback of how he had to give away his
daughter as one of the best moments in
the entire series I had to make the most
difficult decision of my life
I had to do the best thing for mine I
knew if I kept my to the soldier they
would take care of her you can feel his
longing to see his daughter again it's a
great performance from bound Coleman and
a great atmosphere built around him it
took me 20 years until I could finally
get out of the country sometimes it is
so difficult I almost give up hope but I
never stopped thinking about her I will
never stop trying I would give anything
to see her again this might be one of
the best animated Christmas specials I
have ever seen it features a few amazing
moments from Helga are you fat cold
look into your heart and we've got a
choice either you and I work all night
to find a certain Las doctor are you
gonna leave now but if you leave now
that little football-headed kid will
never believe in miracles again but
nothing beats the reunion of mr. Wynn
and his daughter can't believe it
my disagrees you
it captures the spirit of the season in
a way that doesn't feel preachy
it feels genuine and personal without a
doubt one of the show's best
[Music]
number two parents day from season five
this episode gets emotional
Arnold's class is holding a parent's
tournament weekend and his grandparents
are excited to compete with him but it
seems Arnold himself doesn't want
anything to do with it this year he's
feeling down about not having his own
parents around and this leads to his
grandfather detailing what happened to
them and why they've been absent from
the nine year olds life along with it's
heartbreaking story the theme to this
episode is one of the saddest things
I've ever heard
this is the first time we heard about
what happened to Arnold's parents and
their back story presented here is
something fans were waiting four years
to hear what happened to Grandpa he
never came back
yeah we heard from them again what about
your plane we never found
Arnold dreams of his last moments with
his parents and the times immediately
following their evident demise the
ending to the episode is a touching
melancholy but also somehow hopeful
moment are you crying no how we stopped
doing that we love they are and we all
know that there are way more than just
five amazing episodes so here are some
honorable mentions that we would highly
recommend as some of the best in the
series
[Music]
and the number one best hey Arnold
episode is the journal parts 1 & 2 from
season 5 we want to talk about heart
breaking the journal is still a gut
punch to watch on the anniversary of his
parents disappearance Arnold has had
enough of hearing about his mom and dad
while nearly giving up hope on their
return that changes when he finds his
father's journal which presents many
details he never knew all from his
father's perspective this includes how
gut-wrenching it was for him and his
wife to leave their one-year-old son
this covers some of the events that were
outlined in parents day but it goes much
deeper into those happenings to give us
a clearer picture of just what went
wrong and who Arnold's parents really
were they were adventurers who loved
helping others a trait that was
obviously passed on to their son we got
to see how Arnold was born and even the
origins of Abner the pig in this story
Arnold's father's journal ends with a
poignant narration that encapsulated
what made this show stand out I love
every day of our lives together I'm
looking forward to living near my mom
and dad and watching Arnold grow and
learn more and more I feel so lucky I
would do anything in the world for my
lovely Stella and for our dear little
son Arnold well it answered some
questions for us the journal left us
with a few bigger ones particularly the
ending tease that was up in the air for
15 years
[Music]
Hey Arnold captured our imagination with
a realistic setting relatable characters
authentic perspective spot on comedy and
sentimental storytelling it's as
enjoyable today as it was all those
years ago maybe more so as the series
continues to gain new fans the jungle
movie will close out a story many of us
have been following for over 20 years
and will finally help us off a specific
cliff we've been hanging on for 15 Hey
Arnold had it all and in the words of
mr. Simmons it will always hold a
special place in our hearts over on my
personal channel you can check out an
episode of the countdown continue where
I talk more about the honorable mentions
from this list I'm also going to discuss
the first Herald movie in the lead-up to
Thursday's premiere we want to hear what
you guys think what is your favorite
episode of Hey Arnold what do you want
me to cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know you can also
follow me on twitter at Tamra L chambers
and YouTube at Tamra Lynne chambers you
can like my Facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome Walter B and follow along
on Twitter to take part in more polls
about what may be covered in the future
come back next week for our brand new
episode of top 5 see you later football
head you're tearing me apart Olga
[Music]
you